bonjour jérôme marty jours ravi de vous
retrouver dans la matinale berthet
france il ya un conseil sanitaire ce
matin pour faire face à l'augmentation
des cas de contamination des cas qui
augmente notamment dans les écoles que
faudrait-il faire selon vous pour
empêcher en tout cas que la
contamination ne se propage davantage
dans les écoles
mais qu'est ce qu'il n'aurait pas fallu
faire surtout on a changé le protocole
qui fonctionne et on a changé un poteau
paul n'était pas ce qu'il savait sur le
fait de fermer une école jamais le jazz
du moins des restants où l'on trouvé une
forme positif et là on évolue le
photocall qui passez moi le terme est
assez et déconnant puisque on va isoler
laurent positif mais on va tester les
autres enfants et on va isoler seulement
les autres en forme qui serait positif
sauf que on oublie que les contaminants
quatre jours avant d'être
détectable ce qui veut dire que l'enfant
positif à contaminer d'autres enfants et
quand on détecte ses enfants car ils ne
sont pas encore positif ils vont
continuer aussi à transmettre donc en
fait faut résumer ça plutôt que fermer
le robinet du flux virale
le protocole bancaire l'a ouvert en
grande et ça ça pose un énorme problème
moment où la circulation virale est très
importante sur le territoire alors dans
le contexte actuel il ya eu l'idée de la
fermeture des écoles une semaine avant
les vacances de noël aux officiels est
ce que c'est un moyen le moyen le plus
efficace sont pas forcément aujourd'hui
elle sort était valable certainement à
valenciennes autocall pour vraiment
bloqué les choses mais là ça arrive
presque trop tard puisque les taux
d'incidence aussi importants qui sont
historiquement haut et vous l'avez eu
plus de 900 décida d'aller dans les
classes chez les chez les enfants ça
veut dire que healy a énormément de
porter virale et donc le fait de les
envoyer dans des familles et les envoyer
en gare de meroux risque de discerner le
virus un peu plus dans les familles
chassées la première chose et puis
attention qu'est-ce qu'on fait par
exemple pour les enfants des soignants à
un moment où on manque de soignants
partout est ce que c'est vraiment la
bonne chose que dès que d'isoler ou de
notables et des histoires liant à la
maison de marthe et les enfants je crois
qu'il faut tester tester isolé tester
tester tester beaucoup plus il faut des
protocoles d'aération des détecteurs de
co2 des purificateurs d'air dans les
écoles ça n'a pas été fait c'est un peu
tard mais nord mais il faut accélérer
accélérer accélérer au dessus ces
mesures ont été préconisées même par
vous depuis très longtemps
cela dit c'est on parle bien du varions
delta aujourd'hui par rapport à ces à
ces contaminations dans les écoles a
priori les parents vaccinés sont
relativement à l'abri alors pourquoi
finalement mettre en cause des enfants
est une très bonne réflexion les parents
vaccinés sont à l'abri mais il ya encore
trop de non vaccinés il y a encore trop
de personnes qui sont à plus de six mois
de la deuxième vaccination il ya encore
trop de personnes qui n'ont pas fini
leur cycle vaccinale et c'est ça qui
pose problème je leur paie colle encore
quatre cent mille personnes âgées qui ne
sont pas vaccinés eux ils rien à une
grosse cohorte de patients entre 60 et
70 ans qui ne sont pas vaccinés au qui
n'ont pas fini leur talent leur cycle
vaccinale vous le voyez le chiffre
important nous avez cité ce matin c'est
plus de 2400 la réanimation ça veut dire
que la même pathologie occupe plus d'un
tiers des lits de réanimation et ça ça
pose problème on a déjà connu ça
auparavant ce qu'on veut éviter par tous
les moyens c'est des programmations cd
perte de chance pour d'autres malades et
du coup est ce que la vaccination des
enfants selon vous doit se poser
aujourd'hui on sait il va y avoir des
bases sur le volontariat dès janvier
2022 qui devrait être annoncé quel est
votre avis sur cette vaccination des des
plus jeunes
déjà si on mars il les enfants ce sera
évidemment pas pour cette vague ce qu'il
faut se dire que ce sera pour les vagues
suivantes en doute pas pour la
persistance virale que l'on aura
malheureusement connaître pendant des
mois et des mois et des mois puisque le
virus est installé la question se pose
évidemment pour les enfants qui sont à
mobilité pour les enfants qui sont à
risque et on rappelle qu'il y l'enfant
hospitalisée en nombre il y à de très
faibles car heureusement de décès chez
les enfants mais il y a des enfants
hospitalisés dont la question se pose
pour le reste pour la vaccination on va
dire préventif qui toucherait tous les
ans forme il faut que l'on ait vraiment
tous les éléments de bénéfice risque les
éléments de doses à utiliser pour que ce
soit sur cette position là pour
l'instant on n'a pas encore il ya une
dichotomie néanmoins le gouvernement qui
appelle à se faire faire une troisième
dose et un accès très compliqué au
vaccin aujourd'hui code qu'en pensez
vous mais là aussi la foulée je vous
dise pour l'enlever système qui
fonctionne bien on avait les
vaccinations se faisait d'art et
habillées aux côtés de centres de
vaccination aux côtés de vaccinodromes
et on a fermé les votes cynodrome on a
fermé la dictée de centres de
vaccination on avait prévenu que ça
allait poser problème parce que nous
n'avons pas de monodoses dans les
cabinets est donc structurellement ça
pose des problèmes de rendez vous dédié
la vaccination alors même qu'on a une
grosse demande de soins dans nos
cabinets pour l'éventualité
gastroentérite les greens les affections
saisonnière plus ces maladies chroniques
il a on est en train d'être un sport de
ré ouvrir des centres de vaccination on
aurait mieux fait de ne pas les fermer
du tout merci beaucoup jérôme marty pour
votre éclairage ce matin je le rappelle
vous êtes médecin généraliste président
de l'unef m elle co vide